the first season of warrior nun from
series creator Simon berry has finally
dropped on Netflix and the
demon-fighting adaptation of Ben Dunn's
cult hit comic doesn't disappoint but
did the ending leave you scratching your
head a little here's a breakdown of
everything that transpired in that
apocalyptic final episode but first a
bit of backstory series protagonist ava
is a paraplegic orphan living out her
days in a pretty unpleasant looking
Spanish convent in the very first
episode of warrior nun she dies under
mysterious circumstances and the nun who
brings her body to receive last rites
doesn't seem to be too broken up about
it
Ava was apparently a challenging Ward
and you get the sense that the nuns from
the orphanage aren't exactly sorry to be
unburdened by her care shortly after
Ava's body arrives at the Spanish
monastery a team of demon slaying nuns
from the order of the cruciform sword or
OCS burst in carrying the mortally
wounded body of the comrade Shannon
masters a band of health fawn are hot on
their tails however and the devils and
demons soon penetrate the monasteries
defenses one of the nuns uses a set of
tongs to remove a glowing artifact from
Shannon's back which they refer to as
the halo no surprise the demons are
after the halo and it's apparently of
the utmost importance that they not get
their hellacious claws on it one of the
nuns evades capture and hides the halo
inside Ava's corpse Ava is promptly
resurrected by the artifacts insertion
and guess what she's no longer paralyzed
not only that but she seems to have
acquired a pretty radical set of
superpowers including super strength and
super healing while the series opens
with a real bang the plot drags a bit in
the middle of the season when the focus
shifts from the existential struggle
between good and evil to a more mundane
character story as Ava rapidly explores
the contours of her new life as a normal
young woman thankfully this slower
storyline falls by the wayside by the
time the season reaches its conclusion
and Ava finds herself smack-dab in the
middle of a centuries-long struggle of
literally biblical proportions episode
10 opens up with Ava still locked inside
the tomb where she ended up at the end
of episode 9 the rest of the OCS are on
the outside looking in
she isn't alone down there however the
entity age real who falsely presents
himself as an angel is inside the tomb
with our revenant heroine and he's got a
story to tell
Adriel tells ava that the halo in her
back was stolen from him by OCS founder
Ariela in the year 1066 and since then
he's been on a millennial mission to get
it back Adriel claims that the church
has kept him sealed away inside the tomb
because they know he can't be defeated
in the mortal world this is a bit of a
head scratcher for Ava who doesn't
understand why the church wouldn't be
all about a real-life angel that they
could parade around in front of the
Vatican thus confirming their long-held
beliefs according to Adriel the church
thrives on faith they don't want to
confirm their beliefs because they have
weaponized faith itself to achieve power
and control over people without doubt
there can be no faith which pretty much
precludes dressing up an omnipotent
angel and trotting him out for mass
Adriel then thrust Ava into a flashback
sequence in which she watches areolas
near death and resurrection by halo play
out right in front of her eyes Ava seems
on the verge of turning over the halo to
Adriel at this point he is an angel
after all supposedly
the sacrifice might kill her but it will
also save the other OCS sisters waiting
outside the tomb self-sacrifice in this
instance certainly feels like the
Christian thing to do per a VA's Vision
Adriel may have been the original source
of the halo but he didn't bring it down
from heaven through Airy yellows eyes
Ava sees Adriel emerging into a medieval
battle from a demonic portal he's
followed by a demonic tarrasque
which he quickly destroys using the halo
which seems more like a crude armament
in this context than some kind of holy
artifact believing he must be a warrior
of Christ
the Crusaders foolishly pledged
themselves to a drill after watching him
vanquish the Tarasque
back inside the tomb Ava confronts a
drill with this knowledge outed the
entity confesses that he is no kind of
angel at all I don't want to have to
hurt you Ava
awesome
don't Adriel reaches inside ava in an
attempt to remove the halo but ava
fights him off just as beatrice and the
other OCS warrior nuns blow up the walls
of the tomb in a rescue attempt
the sisters pull Ava out of the rubble
and attempt a tactical retreat but
Adriel is far from vanquished they
engage the boss demon in a well
choreographed fight sequence that stalls
him just long enough for Ava to recharge
the halo and draw a divinium sword
Adriel counters by summoning a score of
demons to possess the by standards and
the episode suddenly ends this isn't the
only cliffhanger either
in the B story Michael tells his tearful
mother that his angel is coming back for
him just as the boy appears on death's
door the stargate looking artifact back
at architects spontaneously turns on
generating some kind of portal michael
rushes through and disappears an act
that christian refers to as divine will
so where does this leave us
despite the contrived cliffhangers we
actually learned quite a bit in this
episode most importantly we now know
that Ava's powers have no divine origin
and that the halo in her back is
actually some kind of demonic weapon
carried up from Hell by Adriel when and
if season 2 reaches Netflix will be
eager to see if Ava's divinium sword has
what it takes to vanquish her demon not
to mention where the heck Michael ended
up check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite Netflix originals
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
you